I think the unique personality of
titanfall single-player campaign comes
from its sheer variety we have an
experience that I don't feel like I get
anywhere else right now you can get
different tightened load outs and
experience the different flavors of
titans from the multiplayer in the
single-player big set piece moments we
have like epic combat spaces but then we
also have low key moments where you're
just progressing through the environment
and exploring you're using your pilot
mobility we've actually brought puzzle
mechanics into the fray some of them are
light puzzles that actually require you
to stop and think about the environment
and look around we've got encounters
with really strong enemy characters
they're like boss battles and his bosses
all have some very eclectic interesting
personalities well now the first step in
the process for titanfall to that I
really remember was the action block
face each week the entire design team
would go off and they would have an
opportunity to be creative independently
it freed up the team to just concentrate
on what were the basic building blocks
of single player gameplay the ideas
would get pulled together into a place
where they could start to form the nexus
for a level one of the action blocks
that made it into the game was the
experiment we work with cranes these
wall running panels that were suspended
from cables and the movement position
and use those to make your way through
the level
the great thing about seeing a player
and titanfall 2 is that it's not just
defined by one thing what does it mean
to focus on a Titan Fighting another
tight what does it mean to be a pilot
that's being helped by is tight and what
makes the focus on the bonds so
important to single player is it really
reinforces that there are two units at
work here they have to work together
because we want to build a relationship
between you and BTW we often do things
where we split you guys up you get out
of bt you look at the environment the
objective might be that way but then
you'll see something looks interesting
over there you go over there and try it
out and see what you can find but then
there's this added layer of your
stronger together trust me
this game it's not just corridors it's
wide opportunities that embrace our
motion model instead of trying to gauge
the bird we're going to be able to put
something out there and have people get
an experience that's uniquely titanfall
campaigns and single player and shooters
they can be more they can be more varied
and more adventure like
you